botar todos obrigados a vou passar uns
cinco minutos não é contar um pouquinho
a minha experiência minha história e nem
todo mundo conhece não é um fim não é
comum como foi minha vivência como é com
o que eu fiz que é contestada fazer bem
para chegar onde estou
na verdade há pouco estava lembrar não é
dispensado de ofício foi a criação de 11
no primeiro trabalho que eu fiz e fui
para a criação do novo aquilo que já fiz
vários um dos mais conhecidos por
exemplo foi o logotipo da polícia
nacional do logótipo a bandeira está a
andar
fiz foi para uma empresa de informática
combinamos 20m discutir isso há há há
dez anos atrás não é uma empresa que tem
dois existe a presença do logotipo no
final foi todo dos desmatadores receber
os 21 discutir 20 enquanto ele conta que
10 quando cancelou assim eu só dei um
grande risco antes e fui sair não é a
não vaga em drogas e assim como discutir
na verdade isso como está realmente
existe todo um percurso não é tudo traz
o que é o sucesso
vou começar a contar uma pequena
história do joão é uma pequena criança
de oito anos não estava na loja com com
a avó enquanto a avó comprou bilhetes
não é loteria e espadas e o jogo estava
pode arranjar um bilhete estava de bom
humor naquele dia que só quem toma eo
john joão a felicidade ele conseguiu
ganhar com isso o único bilhete que
estavam dadas ganhou 200 dólares
todo o conteúdo joão foi com uma
bicicleta colocou na porta da casa e
roubar uma bicicleta
obviamente tudo que vem fácil vai mais
fácil além das vezes não é o final do
ano uma família de joão disse john
este ano como tbem não é
no final do ano não voltar vamos dar 200
dólares e pode comprar o que quiser com
os donos da loja
então chegou natálio joão todo contente
já observava se na altura com um dólar
que eu consiga ganhar
com 200 dólares possa faturar muito
dinheiro então joão foi e como a família
já tinha prometido pelo podia fazer o
que quisesse com o dinheiro comprou 200
doses de estética e um foi expandido bom
foi expandido e no final só conseguiu
fazer 15 dólares
com isso ele o joão aprendeu uma das
grandes lições da primeira grande lição
de vida dele não é o sucesso nada tem a
ver com sorte o sucesso nada tem a ver
com do trio na verdade é todo o curso
que nós fazemos não é só vamos ver os
grandes homens homens que nós conhecemos
grandes projetos grandes marcas sempre
eles tentam se superar
não é sempre um grande projeto à frente
sempre tentam fazer mais mas
infelizmente com a sociedade nos ensina
o que nós vemos tampado na revista é o
artista hoje lançou hits e no dia
seguinte é um super está não é é um é
uma senhora linda uma miúda gira que
está no café e depois ao sair do café
enquanto a companhia se encantar com o
que nos é ensinado na grade
mas às vezes o mais importante onde nós
pretendemos chegar mas é toda a
caminhada
muitas vezes as pessoas não sabem todo o
desafio que nós enfrentamos na vida
enfrentamos hoje todos os dias na
verdade a única diferença quando as
pessoas então para ter sucesso muito
pelo contrário os meus gigantes é que
são maiores os desafios é que só amanhã
hoje é só isso na outra diferença
obviamente nós vamos alcançando uma
outra coisa também que o prendia ao
longo desses anos é que muitas vezes nós
devemos valorizar
hoje nós temos opinião como é uma
constante busca não é que nós como seres
humanos
às vezes enfrentamos a crise existencial
podemos ter dinheiro sucesso poder fama
mas muitas vezes sempre nos sentimos
sócios vazios não é e como eu disse mais
importante é a caminhada que nós
traçamos
como de sucesso nada tem a ver com com
um loteria ou com a só mas qual é o
segredo do sucesso
o qual é o segredo da precisávamos
contar o segredo da vida e ficamos por
aqui ok
ainda acho que falta mais um jogador
havia uma pequena vila muito pacata um
pescador
segundo o turista americano estava
deitado na espreguiçadeira e o senhor
não quer que todos aqui todos seus
colegas a trabalharem e tudo aqui é
descansar ainda são duas da tarde eva
não eu fui já pesquei não é um dos
países que têm menos da minha família
com meus filhos para a escola e estou
aqui não é descansar um pouquinho e
tristeza porque não tá não porque não
continuar a apostar que o motorista
ficar mais peixes pescados mais espécies
de peixes e vegetais da manhã com uma
vaga aplicar pequenos peixes pouca
quantidade pode comprar um barco que
pode ir mais longe e já todos sabemos
em março mais longe não é mais profundas
peixes maiores
mas porque eu preciso do do barco quando
o pescador
hoje quase us um bar com bots a minha
peças mais peixes peixes vendidos mais
ganhos mais dinheiro consegue colocar um
motor no barco e mais ainda mais longe
de peixes maiores mas porque é preciso
um barco com motor que o buscador amanhã
consegue comprar vários barcos quando
comprando mais baixos barcos por exemplo
pode deixar esse negócio de país e
começa a atravessar os turistas vêm à
vila não é um lado a outro do lado o
turismo não é e deixa essa cena de seu
buscador mas porque preciso de comprar
um hiato por exemplo com um iate amanhã
arranjos mais ea ti entrevistados a
passar só pessoas com bons saques
maiores mas só passar pessoas e carros e
bem esse outro lado do rio
mas porque eu preciso tudo isso fizesse
isso eu garanto que daqui a 30 40 anos
vai escolher comprar um transatlântico
master cerca de 2 mil pessoas a
trabalharem importante para ti não é só
descansar buscador do povo oportunista
que a licença não estou fazendo
tratamento
e se eu sair desse prédio vida né às
vezes passamos 10 20 e 30 anos a correr
atrás de coisas no final na verdade
queremos é ver a felicidade descanso eu
vou ser uma vida melhor os nossos
familiares nossos filhos não é outra
coisa importante o o mark twain diz uma
vez que os dois dias mas antes da nossa
vida saúde em que nós temos não é o dia
em que você descobre o porquê
uma coisa que me marcou muito e eu
comecei que descobri o meu propósito é
possível na vida foi quando eu li o
livro do sonhador bancar só existe na
igreja adventista eu lembro com 12 mas
com 12 e 11 anos li esse livro é o livro
uma noite só
no dia seguinte educacional todos
sabemos é que há pouco tempo não é como
eu vou ser o presidente dos estados
unidos e hoje em dia é um só posto de
ministro da vida saúde nos estados
unidos é um homem de confiança do
parlamento livro eu não procurei foi
hoje 11 uma criança quer um dos piores
na turma dela a mãe exigiu dela que ela
estudasse que eles muitos livros de lava
tinham um desafio de cerca de cinco
livros por semana que ele tinha que ler
ficava na universidad na na livraria e
depois ter o nosso melhor da sala da
mulher da escola universidade e ele não
foi o primeiro médico a um problema no
nervo senão cirurgião e furtou uma
cirurgia com sucesso em segmentos e ali
eu quero ser a mudança aconteceu numa
altura em que eu estive nos estados
unidos e quando eu cheguei na venda
ainda não vou era havia melhor goleiro
melhor que até pouco tempo três horas de
autocarro e no caminho vianas mortas
quando tentavam dentro de algumas
cidades vilas e se os preços dos
computadores 300 dólares 4 dólares
é o meu primeiro computador quando eu
comprei meu computador meu pai
funcionário público a empresa tentava
vender os conteúdos dos atos compra pelo
preço também discutimos um usado com
mais dez anos
então achei que não é para os novos
marcar a p-31 discutir isto nine
fiquei impressionado intrigado com
aquilo é pá ferramenta que há mais
oportunidades e na altura tive
oportunidades ficando sozinho de hoje em
dia toda essa toda minha família viva
chávez gente mas na altura logo surgiu
algo dentro de mim e ainda com 14 15
anos e disse que é pra não na minha pena
minha família insistiu estiver a ficar
cá consegue estudar é mais fácil nem nos
estados unidos
obviamente são pessoas que passavam 20
anos em ativos por exemplo e os avós 20
anos em bacabeira haver talvez até um
carro quando seguia no g casa né
convertendo na cópia de cadernos mas eu
na altura realmente decepa boca aberta e
quando os oito anos abri minha primeira
impressionável de informática
fui uma das primeiras dispensas pessoas
ou a primeira empresa que trouxe por
exemplo 8 da praia não mudou muita coisa
após isso obviamente que vou sair pela
parte comecei a ter sequência para
televisão
quando cheguei aos estados unidos
lançamos naturativa estava em fase
experimental estava chato relançamos o
canal dos diretores do do canal
televisivo
lançamos o canal durante três anos foi
produtor e realizador e na altura a
minha primeira experiência foi com
programas jogos números do colega eu era
o apresentador reeditou trabalhavam como
é que não é um fundo verde minha câmera
gravar curia falava da minha deixa
depois em editar esse material e colocar
vou continuar por anos acredita em cabo
verde que fazia o uso do serviços de
valor acrescentado postinho ligar não é
fazer uma chamada e podiam ganhar um
prêmio como já tinha empresa o aumento
ficou difícil conjugar as duas coisas né
o objetivo era um outro sobre 34 anos na
estação e de seguir acabou de me dedicar
a cem por cento
isso tem a ver muitas vezes com o
conselho que eu dou as pessoas muitas
vezes nós queremos atingir o sucesso
ou queremos atingir josé couso objetivos
hoje não tem muitas vezes esquecemos que
nós temos obviamente há coisas que nós
temos que sacrificar e eu ao longo não
procurasse que sacrificar a minha a
minha saúde
o usw ordinais causa trabalhar muito já
deram um ano de vida
a dengue uma vez que eu lancei o
vencedor é ativo que é um carro do tipo
quem quer ser um milionário
quando lançamos o esse programa no ar da
manhã e problemas um abscesso hepático
eu criei um beco caso de stress
muitas vezes nós temos que abdicar de
coisas da família do tempo pensamos que
os nossos filhos com com a família em
casa com os amigos para nos dedicarmos
ao projeto muitas vezes temos que nos
sacrificar mesmo lançamos anotou o
vencedor
há cinco anos atrás lançamos na
televisão o esporte à música tv são
canais temáticos este ano vou entrar os
dois dentro da cadeia da programação da
japan dólares a moçambique
o objetivo é preservar o conteúdo toda
nossa cultura africana campeã em
particular pra fora não é
lançamos também há o primeiro reality
show a nível dos palancas o líder tipo
quem quer ser do tipo ab droga não é na
verdade foi esse plus com esse projeto o
vôo esse reality show e depois mundo
volvo angola há quatro anos atrás
abrimos uma empresa em angola da criança
em angola e não assinamos um contrato
com a sap tv produção de conteúdos na em
moçambique e em angola foi derrubado na
área em são tomé o piloto e depois disso
tudo obviamente nós notamos eu não tenho
pessoalmente com uma das coisas que vai
mudar no futuro com grande impacto são
os conteúdos não costumo dar sempre esse
exemplo por exemplo os operadores de
telemóveis oferecer algo telemóvel
ministro brown e para santa luzia o
iphone 23 que um dia já que não existe
ninguém tem hoje em dia eo iphone ex
só que não acontece com o iphone 3 tens
o viber da vida
what's up do vídeo no facebook do vídeo
e no iphone é jogar mas não é
as especificações de todos não tem
nenhum desses aplicativos quadra
poliespotiva fazendo dia o que tem os
aplicativos consegue comunicar tão mais
importante são os conteúdos mas mesmo a
tecnologia só servir de túnel em média
para passarmos da os conteúdos
nos últimos anos nós temos temos
apostado muito enquanto tim e se foi no
ano passado realizamos em dezembro em
cabo verde a maior luta de boxe africano
título peso pesado box africano está em
aberto com o marroquino e um congolês e
nenê foi o maior feito não foi só a
dimensão da luta mas sim porque é essa
luta
nós conseguimos resolver um dos grandes
desafios do negócio que é o acesso ao
mercado todos nós sabemos como ela ganhe
pequeno não é fazer uma luta custa 16
mil contos encher o genótipo vivo com
três mil pessoas por ano sendo
discutidos obviamente não faz sentido
mas nós já tiver poder pegar esse
conteúdo mas com criar produzir um plano
contínuo que seja premium
ok qualidade é top qualquer pessoa no
mundo pudesse comprar e vender ao mundo
e nós conseguimos assinar com a internet
é a mesma empresa empresa número um no
mundo de venda de conteúdo pay-per-view
e on demand mesma empresa todos os
contratos por exemplo da luta do
econômico é que o flight level né mesmo
empresas nos conhece e conseguimos
transmitir esses conteúdos esse conteúdo
disponível para 62 milhões do caso em
todos estados unidos em todo o canadá em
todo o caribe e foi nós conseguimos
abrir a porta e hoje em dia por exemplo
nós queremos a a produzir transmitir um
evento de carro preto com o mundo é
fácil já temos essa relação a esse
contato esse caminho já criados não
resolvemos essa questão do conteúdo
também no mesmo evento conseguimos
trazer para cabo verde
o príncipe do barein que na altura os
gols acaba perdido custou um milhão de
dólares com sua viagem trouxe um avião
que entrava na cidade da praia
não é com toda outro com todo seu
palácio de 40 pessoas né só para virem
ver o conteúdo irá ver com um uma luta
de boxe muito e muito muito impacto
muitas vezes é das nossas próprias
narrativas que conseguimos
principalmente uma opção nós mesmo no
mundo isso é muito importante
o que acontece hoje em dia é em relação
à áfrica o que motiva é que muitas vezes
nós não somos nós a contar a nossa
história por exemplo nós todos nós todos
os dias ouvimos histórias horríveis tvs
vem dos estados unidos
mas todo mundo quer que os estados
unidos não é
todos os dias mas muitas vezes não
acontece o mesmo em relação à áfrica
porque muitas vezes não somos nós
ok os criadores da nossa própria
história e os contadores quando somos
nós entendemos o problema e comunicamos
no sentido de resolvermos esse problema
busquei importante não seremos nós é um
trabalho que depende não só de
produtores de conteúdo cinema música os
jornalistas também a maneira como nós
contamos a nossa própria história pois
nós por isso que nós nesse momento o meu
enfoque principado é todo toda a
capacidade disponível em aberto mesmo
aplicando nós podemos criar conteúdos de
qualidade por exemplo essa luta de boxe
está doente é um mercado mais difícil
para aprender boxe porque nós optamos
pela pelo pela realização de um evento
peso pesado box aplicando conheça com
esse evento sem ficar num evento o vice
presidente da união africana de boxe que
por acaso o presidente da união fica no
box que por acaso o vice presidente do
clube se aos meninos do box 11 dias nos
convidaram para nós realizarmos uma luta
já de título mundial em cabo verde e e
hoje em dia é um desafio que nós temos
nós já passamos por exemplo o acesso à
informação que é um direito universal
acho que todos nós já passamos por isso
tentamos abrir um conteúdo no youtube e
tem jeito contido nossa disponível no
seu país não é bom vamos ao itunes que
vamos comprar uma música eu tenho
dinheiro pra pagar tem um cartão de
crédito mas muitas vezes continuam está
disponível pois o meu pedido à região
onde estão inseridos em muitas vezes
acontece é em áfrica
é por isso que hoje nós os africanos
começarmos a criar os nossos copos
conteúdos e contarmos a nossa própria
história e ninguém consegue contar de
forma e qual a parte disso os conteúdos
eo importante para a áfrica é a questão
das tecnologias obviamente a tecnologia
amor da áfrica
um dos aplicativos hoje em dia está
criado o gum sabe nós sabemos das
dificuldades que os agricultores tenham
acesso ao crédito bancário
um dos problemas é que realmente não tem
a ver com o banco pede informações eles
não têm informações de países um
aplicativo em um candidato
o agricultor todas as contas do gado do
porco da ração e feito através do
aplicativo e consegue gravar todas as
transações e o banco pega nessas
transações e hoje já consegue dar
crédito por exemplo da tecnologia têm
estado a mudar e também há pouco tivemos
o testemunho não é desses jovens
brilhantes não lançado em 9 tende a
mudar a nossa economia rural do nosso
país da nossa cidade e nós há um ano
atrás começamos com essa também é esse
desafio que hoje em dia já há vários
iniciativas várias iniciativas no país
o ensino do coaching formamos 130
crianças em coaching 40 professores das
escolas associadas da unesco escolas de
beebe
e há duas semanas por exemplo estamos
também um programa piloto com a escola e
dizer vamos ensinar os 1800 67 anos a
programarem até os copos jogos seus
próprios aplicativos muitas vezes nós
ficamos fascinados quando eu vejo meu
tempo meu filho algo abandona mas o dia
fica mais satisfeito quando eu vejo meu
filho a criar um dom
o povo dona funciona certo e como disse
exemplo e hoje em dia nós o que eu estou
a trabalhar num projecto global combina
onde comida todos os canais toda a
tecnologia é a construção de um dos
grandes centros em alta em cabo verde
para a áfrica do contínuo de produção de
conteúdo de tecnologia e não posso meias
extremos
já fomos convidados para estarmos em
três grandes eventos nos estados unidos
em off e também em bruxelas não é
respeitamos a procura de financiamento
vai materializar isso esse projeto eu
vejo a questão dos contínuos da
tecnologia de forma integrada
vamos começar a atacar pela parte da
base que é a questão da qualidade dos
conteúdos não é que muitas vezes em
áfrica não a formação e os conteúdos têm
menos qualidade com isso nós não
encontramos muitos conteúdos na netflix
sejam aplicados queremos formar pessoas
nesses campos vai haver uma única
universidade quando me toca rock vai
haver hotéis onde os artistas podem vir
gravar as músicas de ficar lá dentro um
homem capturado a 15 mil pessoas e
obviamente nós queremos a nossa visão é
de forma compreensiva toda a áfrica há
500 anos atrás cabo verde desempenha um
papel importante no mundo não é
olha os carros todas as mercadorias
fluíam da áfrica com muito rock e hoje
em dia nós também queremos fazer o mesmo
agregar conteúdos a valor esses
conteúdos e vender esses pontos do mundo
áfrica conta só para 3% de todo o
tráfego de internet no mundo que tem um
bilhão de pessoas e os especialistas já
prevêem que até 2050 a população aumenta
para mais de 2 bilhões de pessoas não
temos um mercado e há dois meses um mês
atrás nós lançamos esse tipo de
dispositivo deve terminar é um
dispositivo foi desenhado totalmente por
nós já temos o protótipo já temos
fornecedor quanto produzir 5 - 1 milhão
10 milhões de dispositivos é um
dispositivo pode estar protegidos 15
dólares hoje em dia só 10% das casas em
toda a áfrica tem um computador em casa
no colubandê problema às vezes pagamos
toda a questão do custo da internet mas
o ganho dos problemas também o custo dos
dispositivos
se um computador custa 30 - curtos e uma
existem famílias sozinhas ganhou 25 das
promessas e fica impossível não vou
chegar lá não é esse dispositivo pode
estar porque os 35 delas é um só a
grande vantagem que é um mesmo
dispositivo um mesmo dispositivo que
funciona como computador possa aceder à
internet foi a no horto no excel fazer a
pesquisa os alunos estão em casa
pesquisar
eu estou a trabalhar numa folha de
cálculo excel mas também uma certa box
estamos a desenvolver conter a isso uma
plataforma de venda do conde útil à
frente de todas
finalmente eu quero ser um exemplo para
rockhampton enquanto evitem o clássico
sequer terminou com tudo lá dentro tem
que desenvolver um aplicativo custa 5
mil e 10 mil anos nosso aplicativo
consegue criar um canal em cinco minutos
logo seu conteúdo já consegue vender
para o mundo inteiro e também funciona
como um decodificador de televisão
digital
por isso num único dispositivo é
realmente é disso que a áfrica aplicando
possível e eu fico contente quando eu
vejo que há várias iniciativas
esses jovens estão a desenvolver
aplicativos e realmente nós também
precisamos não é de forma mais macro
essas plataformas onde os jovens podem
ver os jovens podem vender seus
conteúdos
há uma dificuldade enorme em nível de
produtor de conteúdos em áfrica
colocaram seus conteúdos da fé
por causa da cor da qualidade com acesso
a financiamento
enquanto confio nos estados unidos é
produzido por 200 milhões de dólares
nigéria não lhe ruth que produz até mais
firmes em hollywood a 91 da nigéria
pontos mais críticos em termos de
quantidade por um filme só com cinco mil
dólares como eu diz somos nós que temos
que criar nossa própria narrativa e as
nossas próprias ferramentas deixarmos
não só utilizar tecnologia que é feita
lá fora mas que muitas vezes não são
práticos como eu consigo comprar um
computador consegue com soma 800 volts
se existem localidades em cabo verde em
toda a áfrica que sequer têm acesso à
energia em vez de construir um
computador
o consumo 800 votos e construído pela
suíça tipos de construir esse
dispositivo só consome 10 watts consegue
se alimentar com uma pilha é mais dez
votos mais que suficiente
temos que ter nossos consultores e
sermos nós a contar a nossa própria
história